las dos acusaciones por violación en
contra de damián abad datan del año 2010
y 2011 sin embargo apenas se conocieron
públicamente este fin de semana por un
artículo del medio en internet mediapart
en la primera de ellas la mujer había
denunciado en el año 2002 y en el año
2017 sin embargo ambas investigaciones
fueron cerradas por la justicia por
falta de pruebas la segunda mujer apenas
denunció en mayo de este año frente al
observatorio de violencia sexistas y
sexuales en la política que nació del
movimiento mixto política de hecho este
observatorio dice haber alertado al
partido de los republicanos el ex
partido de abad y el partido de la
república en marcha el presidente manuel
macro de esta segunda denuncia en que la
mujer además de haber sido drogada por
el diputado y ahora ministro para abusar
de ella sexualmente el damián abad se
defiende dice que son acusaciones falsas
que en ambos casos se trató de
relaciones sexuales consentidas y que él
tiene una minusvalía que le impide
justamente tener relaciones sexuales sin
el consentimiento de la otra persona por
parte del gobierno dicen que ellos no
sabían nada que cuando se eligió
ministro no se consulta a los partidos
políticos sino que la sal está auto de
la transparencia y la vida pública y a
las finanzas públicas pero que apenas se
supo este caso la primera ministra se
reunió ayer con damián a bad boy olivia
agregar la nueva portavoz reiteró cuál
es la línea de este gobierno de
elisabeth von que además ha puesto a la
mujer como gran causa el quinquenio que
justamente tolerancia cero con los
autores de violencia sexual en contra de
las mujeres estimular la liberación de
la palabra para que las mujeres sigan
denunciando olivia agree war llamó
también a cualquier persona que
eventualmente haya sido víctima o
considerar sido agredida sexualmente por
también abad para que también denuncia
el caso pero recordó que por ahora es la
justicia la que debe determinar la
veracidad o no de estas acusaciones